I want to say something upfront and uh I
want to say that I I appreciate and I
love Tiger belly fans I really do
I dream about you guys I wanna have
sexual intercourse with every single one
of you male or female and I just love
you but there are just certain things
that I want to throw out there things
not to do okay
last night I was at the Comedy Store
packed room people are in the room I go
up till a couple of first jokes and then
all of a sudden I hear from the back
George as a big jack and it just puts
and then I have to explain to the
audience I have a podcast we have a
producer his name is George he has a
pink dick you know I know it is going
why would you know I mean then I have to
explain why I would even have to say
that he has a pink dick which is because
of the fact that he's white you know and
it's a whole thing right that's number
one not to yell out that out okay number
two if I'm in a a meeting ya know it's
what I got no every single Amy I'll walk
by someone to go to the bathroom and
someone will yell out in an a meeting
hey dude
George is a pink dick and I want to go
ladies up there talking about God and
about you know how they saved her life
if you yell up George is a pink dick out
loud then I have to explain everyone to
the room with that [ __ ] that means
and I don't want to do that none of the
time you know me and then everyone think
I'm gonna realize I realize it's awkward
Bobby a relapse he's on heroin because
you know I mean people now are yelling
he's sucking guys dicks dicks he knows
everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah like I'm sucking up
George yeah in the bathroom
I got the code code phrase so the tooth
places not to yell that out are those
two environments other than that if I'm
driving down the street walking down the
street you mean you can say George's a
pink dick you can just yellow Tiger
belly that works that works fine too
that's a good one yeah good in a show or
in a a meeting you can yell out Tiger
belly Yeah right because then I can go
it's a podcast he's you know he's a new
whenever or in a show that's my daddy's
a fan of the time the choice is a pink
dick there's too much to explain right
Georgia's a pink dick was only to be
used for a photo op if you wanted a
photo with Bobby that's what you would
say yeah yeah he does have one though
yes you know
[Music]